what did I do what I do I Ain
burnishing where's my weapon where's my
weapon where's my weapon a Florida man
decides to Bear all after going into a
drunken rant and threatening to fight
deputies it happened on October 22nd in
Palm Coast Florida when deputies
responded to a report of a man acting
belligerent and arguing with a woman in
the street what address give me the
address cuz he said the same what
address who called other than that
standing right there where where
authorities say 40-year-old Shawn Madden
who you see here went on a drunken and
profanity Lac tiate as he screamed at
Flagler County sheriff's deputies who
were attempting to deescalate the
situation I don't give so listen let's
go I'm swinging on everybody I'm
swinging on everybody I give a I give a
go
ahead why don't we just fall down just a
little bit nope I ain't Cal down for
shit why you think you're rolling up and
you're telling me to calm down I'm just
asking no I I ain't doing it I ain't
doing it I ain't doing it I did shit
wrong what's going on bud as deputies
continue to calm Madden down that's when
he decides to well to let it all out can
we talk about it first about what what
do what do I ain't
banishing where's my weapon where's my
weapon where's my weapon nowhere what am
I brish what did I do go ahead that's
three charges three for what for what
did I do well you can't just pull down
your pants in the middle of the road Bud
oh really but yet four people can roll
up on me and hold their hand behind
their back and act like they're going
to do violence to me and I can't do but
shortly after Madden decides to
surrender to law enforcement and they
arrest him without incident take me down
you're questioning it right now and I
see he hey I appreciate that that's the
that's the way to go bro that's the way
to go I appreciate it Madden was cuffed
and taken to jail he was charged with
disorderly intoxication exposure of
sexual organs assault on an officer and
resisting arrests without violence
Madden was later released after posting
a $2,000 Bond meanwhile in Boulder
Colorado Police sees more than
$115,000 holy
got hey
Brett got some but it's not exactly what
you think police eventually found out
the cash was counterfeit
$77,000 in fake
bills no they look fake according to
Boulder Police the discovery happened
after they stopped a driver who had
invalid temporary tags on their vehicle
once officer searched the vehicle that's
when when police saw what they thought
was the large stack of cash hey Brett oh
got some
fire no they look fake police say the
driver whose name was not released also
gave officers a fake name but once that
real name was revealed cops found out
that he had a felony warrant to appear
in court for a car theft the driver was
charged with criminal impersonation and
possession of an illegal weapon and Tak
into custody next we head to
Massachusetts where police released body
cam capturing what led up to more than
half a dozen children being arrested for
refusing to leave a fast food restaurant
you you're under arrest what you're
under
arrest it happened on October 18th in
Fall River Massachusetts police say they
responded to a local McDonald's after
receiving a service call from a pharmacy
across the street claiming that the
group of teens was causing a disturbance
once the officer arrives he approaches
the cashier area to speak with
management authorities say management
expressed to police that the teens were
not welcome due to several brawls
breaking out which took place prior to
them entering the fast food
restaurant from the manager if you just
walked in time to leave or you got to be
subject to trespass and we'll be
arrested I gave you the warning before
you came in they didn't want you in here
time to leave folks after the officers
gives the group of teens a couple
warnings he dispatches for backup 3
going to any more cars of
McDonald's they want you out man it's
not I'm telling you to go all right you
don't want to go you want to give me a
high time no problem you want give me a
high time cuz how many times did I say
time to go I how many
[Applause]
times if you don't start leaving my
handcuffs are coming on first person I
grab is going shortly after a few more
warnings from the officer one of the
teens in the group becomes
confrontational after refusing to
leave listen from the manager he want
everybody out okay so you either start
leaving I'm telling you that okay I
already taught the manager so either
start leaving or we're going to start
locking people up we have another people
here here here all right time to
go time to
go time to go for what can I know why
huh can I know why cuz he doesn't want
anybody so you mean mad people stay here
we're kicking everybody out we got more
cars coming there's all other people
here not order so get them out right now
I'm talking to
you time to
go what is it g all right that's what it
is go next the body cam captures a group
of teens and the officers outside
McDonald's crowding the entrance as the
teens attempt to go back inside no
problem what you going to do
lock going to get
lock
nig get
my beened up know
Myck then the teens go back inside and
the officer gives his final warning
before making the first arrest last time
all the Cruisers in the city are coming
if you're not saying D you're standing
time to go you you're under arrest what
you're under arrest
yo after the officer cuffs the first
teen they take him outside where he's
shoved to the
[Music]
ground then another teen comes outside
to his friend's defense but he's quickly
blocked by multiple officers who arrest
him as well moments later two officers
can be seen struggling with the entrance
Door one officer opens the door and
appears to grab a teen girl from inside
shoving her to the building
wall
I stand up I'm good the body cam later
cuts to one of the teens explaining
himself to officers saying he was just
hungry you told to leave numerous times
I told you to leave I I told you you
don't come back in theore I told you not
come back in and then you came back get
e I'm hungry I'm going to get food if I
need to get food bro it's like that I
don't care why you have lunch at school
n i don't eat that lunch it's not good
okay so
sure officials say in total eight
children were arrested all of them are
facing trespassing charges while some
are facing additional charges of
resisting arrest disorderly conduct and
disturbing the peace authorities say one
person is also facing charges of assault
in battery on a police officer reporting
for Law and crime Network I'm Elizabeth
Milner